earlier this week I told you about this
obscure law that would make it possible
for congressional committees that deal
with tax information to request Donald
Trump tax returns from the Treasury and
it was Democratic New Jersey congressman
bill Pascrell who wrote a letter to the
House Ways and Means Committee saying
hey let's request Donald Trump tax
returns under this law so that we can
figure out what conflicts of interest or
constitutional violations might exist
but yesterday the committee formally
defeated the effort voting down party
lines Democrats voting YES republicans
voting no to not request Donald Trump's
tax returns from the Treasury and House
Democrats like pastoral and texas
congressman lloyd Doggett who first
proposed the request they wanted to do
this because logically they want to
figure out well Trump there's a lot of
business overseas let's see what
business conflicts there might be let's
see if Donald Trump actually turned over
his businesses to his kids even though
that in and of itself wouldn't be enough
to avoid a conflict of interest let's
see how Donald Trump would personally be
impacted by the tax reform that he's
proposing but hasn't yet done let's
figure out what ties there are between
Donald Trump and Russia and after the
Flynn debacle and the recent revelation
that Trump aids were in touch with
Russia throughout the campaign there's
no greater and more important moment Pat
to check out those tax returns and
Republicans making a political decision
to say we're not going to request them
and although the effort failed this time
I really hope and expect that this keeps
getting brought up within this committee
because these Republicans are going to
have to go back to their constituents
and explain away why they didn't want to
release the information and if three out
of four Americans want to see those tax
returns that's going to be something to
explain well this is a perfect example
of what Pat's alluding to which is the
elected officials that are supposedly
there to represent their constituents
are not acting in the interest of their
constituents because despite what Donald
Trump and Kellyanne Conway have told us
Americans do want to see Donald Trump
tax returns remember the recent ABC
Washington Post poll from just a few
weeks ago which shows as well put up on
the screen for you that's seventy four
percent of a
Americans believe that Donald Trump
should release his tax returns talk
about not representing what your
constituents want and Pascrell insists
as Pat is suggesting quote we're not
going away this is going to come up over
and over and over again congressman
Joseph Crowley from New York saying it's
going to be very uncomfortable in this
committee until the members of the
majority Republicans recognize what's
actually at stake the safety and
soundness of our nation is at stake at
the highest level this is the first time
in 40 years that we've not seen a
president tax returns and for me this is
the instance of the last four years
where we most need to see the
president's tax returns if you had to
predict will we ever see Donald Trump's
tax returns I mean being forced into it
count yes it does also yes I a goalie
and for I don't know why I think we'll
see Trump's tax returns at some point it
may be after he's out of office it may
be because they're hacked in some way I
don't know but I get the feeling it's
just an intuition that at some point
we're going to see them but hey you know
what I thought Hillary Clinton was going
to be the next president of the United
States so what is my prediction matter
clearly it does gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at gamefly offer calm
/ tdps the games are shipped directly to
you would return envelopes included
there's no contracts and you can rent
games through the mobile app get the
free 30-day trial for the david pakman
show audience and support our show by
going to gamefly offer.com slash TDP s